à jean courte il a reconquis la
résidence il nous cachait pas ma joie
est de vous faire des accents obamiens
temps là je commencerai par l'accent
aigu et je sais trop les visites chez
non non je préfère l'accent grave
intervention devant la loi orages ont
les détroits robbins et demi de 2,2 quoi
je vous le demande je me demande à moi
d'autant plus que j'aimerais vous
présenter et un chanteur sympathique
vous connaissez une rico mafia et le lui
va nous parler d'un petit différend
qu'il a eu avec un contractuel ce jour
c'est aléatoire rigaud le petit
grenaille ou allez mes choix
l'autre jour voulant gérer un
stationnement interdit
je suis tombé sur un contractuel et à
son accent j'ai tout de suite vu que
c'était un frère alors on a sympathisé
comme ça en toute franchise et m'a
confié ses problèmes à moi
mais mes proches me
comme une passe des plus belles tenues
drôle mais prochain
sur et les ans
c'était fini
marre de droite moi ces hausses et
suivra
deux noirs sont devenus eux mêmes
je m'accrochais mais l'on m'a conduit
chez nous
j'ai
avec ceux-là purines jeunes ont été durs
pour thème la littérature comme sa
nouvelle avec la disette
et ma journée terminée
il me donna la parole sur la garde au
moins pendant quatre heures non rassurez
vous j'ai le grand plaisir de vous
présenter au grand pêcheur deux amis
tout d'abord notre niveau ville qui
tiendra le rôle d'un contractuel comme
on en voit peu au grade et notre ami
louis de funès ce qu'il me soral chef
discret mais vigilant a les idées quand
un gars vous voulez ça pas d'importance
vous ne vous en faites pas à toute
manière je veux jamais de pv alors je
savais pas sur moi c'est les enfants qui
s'amusent avec à la maison ça fait pas
si chef arrive je joue fait paiera
à
préfère le p je suis là abba abacha vous
avez pas vu de 2,2 vous êtes venus au
rendez vous alors vous ne m'avez pas vu
nous il est vrai que je suis tombé du
ciel
je suis un petit oiseau les menus et je
vous montrerai comment nos pères pour
regarder le coran lab en double file des
votants comme en général de gand c'est
le général non ça ne prend pas vous
n'êtes pas le gagnant et un coup de
pompe au pompon bonbons et me faisait
loin vous lui ont semblé compétitifs à
13 h tu cieux je t'ai reconnu fantômas
où aller enlève ton masque enlève ton
masque de puces toi maintenant que
d'éplucher aller non je ne suis pas 30
mars
à